but I do think Dustin's gonna
incorporate grappling more especially if
uh the light kicks are success early on
by just engaging I think could negate
that with takedowns something from
kicking and I would get into the head I
would say I could see poor a winning via
submission
what is up fam Monday July 24th what is
popping how's everybody's weekend great
grand wonderful a lot of fight news a
lot of fights over this past weekend you
got the big UFC 291 going down this
freaking Saturday and it is a El Grande
pay-per-view
um prelims is whatever they're not great
but that main card is spicy daddy
kicking off with Derrick Lewis Lima yeah
Wonderboy Marco Pierre
markachiasa Kevin Holland Tony Ferguson
Bobby green that's an interesting one
we'll get into that Jan Alex Pierre
Dustin Poirier Justin gaichi should have
been fight of the year they give
somebody else fun 2018 the rematch the
BMF titles on the line I guess that's a
real thing now because we have to say it
I can't wait for this pay-per-view it's
a great card absolutely stacked card
take my money we're doing Cowboys fight
companion this Saturday 7 P.M Pacific
with the boys I got a great crew will
not that soon but I'm excited for this
one
um and we also I'm talking to Luke
Thomas later this week as well so that
will air on Thursday and we'll have
Lukey Thomas the great Luke Thomas I
think the best in the business from top
to bottom the big man himself Luke
Thomas will be joining me to break down
UFC 291 and don't forget kids you got
Earl Spence and Terence Crawford
fighting as well one for the record
Bucks two undefeateds going at it World
title fight on disputed welterweight
Championship is going down on PBC boxing
is that on it's on Showtime hell yeah
shout out to show time for getting that
done
so that's going down as well this
Saturday busy Saturday it's interesting
because you got two well
you got UFC not UFC 291 big deal uh you
got Spence Crawford which should have
been happening for years now it's such a
big fight in boxing I know you guys
aren't the biggest box and heads that's
such a mega fight and then next weekend
I'll be joining Joe Rogan Eddie Bravo
and Brian Callan for a fight companion
on JRE for our boy Corey sandahagan
versus Rob font that's a fight night
that same night my point was you have
big UFC and boxing and then next week
you have decent sized UFC fight night
and you have Jake Paul versus Nate Diaz
so we got
back-to-back weekends if you're a fight
fan
you're happy you are happy
as a pig and [__] as they say
that's the whole thing
but yeah it's going down man
uh you you guys more excited for Jake
Paul Nate Diaz or Terence Crawford Earl
Spence
if you had to pick Jake Paul Nate Diaz
yeah you guys are pieces of [__] I know
God you know good of a fight I know
Crawford
no none of them have lost 39 and over so
what's spent Spence has to be I mean at
least 30 you know 39 over you know at
the hot no he's 28 no dude oh sorry yeah
28 no verse 39 you know the highest
level of boxing ah give me Nate Diaz
Jake Paul
which one does more pay-per-views
that's a good question
I don't know
yeah like if you're even like if you
even have your toe dipped into box and
you're like this is the fight this is a
big [__] deal you guys are loose it's
a big deal but it's just the world we
live in now
uh Jake Paul versus Nate Diaz might do
more pay-per-views which is insane dude
Jake is six and one
just looking at the followers I I think
Spence Crawford because you're talking
about the entire boxing
Community across the world is going to
tune into this yeah
have have uh kg put that up on the the
thick boy page what what sells more
pay-per-views Crawford it's gonna
infuriate boxing fans but what can you
do man
yeah Terence Crawford we've had him on
food truck a long time ago
um
both of these guys aren't they're like
they sleep
eat live boxing like they're they're As
Good As It Gets when it comes to
fundamentals and pedigree and boxing
like there's nobody better but um
neither one is like a character you know
they're not great on social media which
is stupid that that is even plays a role
in this but just 223 so it's what we do
but neither one's like
you know trending on Instagram or
anything like that or in the neither
one's like great on the mic like they're
they're built there's not a lot of build
up to this but I don't think you need it
they're that damn talented but um
yeah I'm curious how that how that does
I don't know Nate had that many
followers makes very famous it's very
famous yes
yeah it's interesting I would assume
Spence and Crawford does more
pay-per-views
now who now
when it comes to Legal streams because
you know Nate Diaz Jake Paul the young
audience they like to like to rip it you
know so if you had illegal streams
probably Nate beats that but
it's a weird world we got a lot of fun
fights man uh we'll get into UFC 291
pretty soon here and then uh Crawford
and Spencer will save the talk with the
expert with Luke Thomas which we'll drop
later this week
um you had a you had a fight card over
the weekend it went down in London
usually the O2 Arena is a special
special place I found myself
bored to tears uh with this card I
started with the very first one I
started at 9 00 a.m Pacific Time on ESPN
Plus
a lot of decisions hate to see that uh
Sean abandon lose to your kind of
handled there's a lot of hype coming
into her
um Ireland loves her but it was tough to
see she just she'll get the last round
but she'll learn from this that was a
bummer to see
um Paul Craig got the win done that was
probably the loudest Applause of the
night besides Tom aspinall
and then
you know your girl Molly meatball mccon
McCain got dealt with Jen oh my girl she
got dealt with she was talking for a
while too yeah oh I know that ref was
like wait what's happening she almost
got her arm [__] ripped off
um yeah it's just a tough gig for I
don't
I mean I see where the UFC doesn't I see
why they don't like she's such a star
especially that women's flyweight
division you need Stars especially out
there in Europe she's a massive star
but they just give her this horrible
match up her Jiu Jitsu is to replay huh
really bad as soon as it hit the ground
it was Game Over game over sexy or lose
um but in the The Talk of the Town is
the main event Tom aspinall if you had
to if you gave me a hundred thousand
dollars and I could bet on one fighter
that I can guarantee he's gonna be a
world champion Tom aspinal
I think the way if you look at the lay
of the land what Tom did to type it type
uh Tiberia
I mean he was a big favorite for a
reason but after that layoff that bad
injury with the knee he's going through
some issues it sounds like his personal
life with his camp and outside of the
gym
um I knew he'd beat him but not like
this I mean it was even competitive and
just what he's been doing lately man the
guy is such a [__] Savage
um he's more athletic than anybody we've
seen he puts it together better than
everybody else in the in the heavyweight
division
the rumor is John retires in Mass Square
Garden after beat Stipe once retire in
his hometown home state of New York so
what a great way to do it in math Square
Garden have to beat uh Stipe which I I
think he mops before with steepe
so let's take John and Stipe out of it
which I think he John hims a tough fight
I could see him get it done stuff like
let's take John out of it he'd beat
Steven so let's take those two out of
let's say they retired so then you're
stuck with
not stock but you're left with yeah
Cyril gone who I think he absolutely
destroys in every facet I think his
speed his timing his athleticism his
overall MMA IQ his ability to not only
stand with uh Cyril gone he's not going
to out strike him but I I do think he
knows something's better on his feet
than Sarah God not his kicks obviously
but I think his speed would be a problem
for sure gone his pressure would be a
problem but the biggest issue for
Shelgon is his ability to adapt from
striking to wrestling to grappling once
it hits the ground shogun's a white belt
that we you know we saw with Jon Jones
he got choked out by a front [__]
Guillotine for God's sakes Against the
Cage so I think you'd have a huge
advantage over Shield gone
he called out the winner of Serial gun
versus is it Sarah
pavlovich is it I know sure right no no
that's not the fight because it's in
Paris oh you're right yeah he's already
beat spin back spare X probably not
gonna win that one so let's say Sarah
God wins that fight
so his and it'd be for interim I would
assume it's for the interim uh
Heavyweight Championship wait that fight
oh it's in September
um
yeah so if that [__] that's soon so that
fight's in September so winner of that
fights Tom Aspen all
probably December you know and then
Tom's next fights for the interim well
just be for the vacant heavyweight title
if John retires
and probably be against Sergey pavlovich
I think he beats Pavlich I think if he
can just avoid that first round he
dragged Pavlich into second third fourth
round he beats him but I just you look
at the matchups take Jon Jones out of it
I don't see anybody beating Tom aspinal
he's too damn good big boy two six five
the kid's a problem black belt on the
ground great hands confidence swaggers
there give me you give me 100 Grand I
bet on one UFC fighter become Champion
the next year it's it's it's uh our boy
Tom aspinel his speed is insane
especially for heavyweight yeah yeah he
gives every just look at the lay of the
land I don't know I mean I'd say his
toughest matchup is Curtis blades
curse blades now though coming off a
loss I think you know
it's sucks to say this and I wonder what
Tom would say but it's almost a blessing
that I mean I'd like to see how Tom does
against a really good wrestler like
Curtis blades but that that's his
toughest matchup stylistically
we didn't get to see it blew his knee
out before the fight even started but
then Curtis blades you know he lost a
Sergey I think they're gonna
for Tom for the benefit of Tom we're
never gonna we're not giving you that
fighting time soon okay I'm a little
worried about Chris Blade's confidence
after that Sergey fight so
hope you had a leapfrog cam I bet Elite
proxim now
and then you got Stipe you got John up
there I'll fight zero gone then you for
the vacant heavyweight title I guarantee
you get Sergey pavlovich versus Tom
aspinal I'll take Thomas all day in that
fight
so shout out to Tom asmore get it done
man let's take a little break we're
talking UFC 291 it's gonna be a big one
you got Crawford Spence going down as
well a few housekeeping notes I'm at the
ice house this Friday one show only a
thing will sell out shop and friends we
got Jay Moore and a bunch other big
names coming up this Friday at the ice
house at 8pm then August 11th two shows
one night August 11th in Phoenix Arizona
catch me at JT Wings when I'm not on
stage my favorite wings in the world uh
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by the best product to get your
mind right get your body right we're
talking about Kratom but you can't trust
any kratom
some of it's a little shady out there
but not my friend said happy hippo I
reached out to them to work with me on
all my shows because I love their
product I love their energy shots their
Kratom shots their gummies they got
powders they got it all they even have K
dips so I have k-dips in right now it's
the it's the Kratom dips like almost you
know if you have tobacco pouches or you
have nicotine pouches this is just
Kratom pouches they have Wintergreen of
Razzle Dazzle I love them you get 20 off
the pouches the shots the energy shots
the Kratom shots the powders the gummies
everything all right everything at
happyhippo.com promo code is thick 23
thick with three C's 23 you save 20 off
for Life off all products as many times
as you want you can share it with your
friend your aunt your buddies your
cousin your Uber driver your Postmates
driver whoever it is share it with them
that's thick23 for 20 off the best
Kratom on the land get you some that's
Happy Hippo dot com promo code is
thick23 you're welcome
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by on it on it they're here to
talk to you about nootropics if you
don't know what Alpha Brain is you're
living under a rock they've sold over a
million bottles but listen the Alpha
Brain is great they give you your money
back if you don't love it you don't have
to return the product you can keep it
share with a friend you you just you're
messing up there it's great helps in
cognitive functions include memory
mental speed and focus but I recommend
Alpha Brain Black that is their black
label it's the highly concentrated Alpha
Brain basically Alpha Brain with a turbo
boost for your brain all right they have
Alpha Brain Black they have regular
Alpha Brain they have the uh Alpha Brain
instant they have Alpha Brain shot they
got it all they have workout
gear as well kettlebell steel Club maces
sandbags yoga mats protein powders
Warrior bars you guys know on it for
God's sakes by now they've been with him
about nine years go to audit.com you get
10 off all for brain products including
the Black Label that I recommend all
workout gear Fitness Gear
streamingfitnessonit.com Shop tension
off now let's get back to UFC 291. but
uh The Talk of the Town is UFC 291 this
freaking weekend it's in Salt Lake City
uh something to think about Salt Lake
City you know the elevation is an issue
especially for the heavier weights uh
Derek Lewis is [__]
I don't know why they did that to my
mans Derek Lewis uh at elevation is not
cool it it even sucks for uh delima
that's not great at that elevation
that's gonna play a factor could play a
factor in yon and Alex Pierre as well
um something to think about with those
heavier weight classes not so much of a
issue for Dustin pori Justin gaichi
Justin gaichi trains at elevation does
employee's been out in Salt Lake for I
think since last week so as long as you
get there about two weeks before it
should be okay
uh for the rest of card it's whatever
but Derrick Lewis is I mean he's just
like all right I got one freaking round
that's it I'm going for a broke and if
you're there maybe that's why the UFC
did it they went dude when whenever your
two has a tent so in order to get your
ass going we know damn well you can't
find the second third round so you got
one round to get this done Derek Lewis
if he knows he only has to go one round
it's a mother trucker he's a Savage as
long as he's going forward anytime you
see Derrick Lewis going backwards he's
losing he's definitely lost that fight
he has to go forward and be the bully
should be able to do again still in but
you gotta realize delima was a 205
before God's sakes
I think he even weighed at 210 one time
like he's he's not a the biggest guy
dick Lewis is a Savage Derek Lewis isn't
really on Instagram anymore
yeah I haven't seen any posts well I
don't follow him but I would still
he was going viral non-stop Rogan would
shout him out post him say he's the best
guy to follow on social media but go to
his Instagram chin can we confirm that I
don't think he's I I don't think he does
it anymore I think once he kind of hit
the
it's just black beast right
his accounts black beast yeah I I think
he stopped
posting so much
I don't see it now
let me actually Google it then yeah I
don't think he erased it but I just
don't think he does it anymore
maybe it's too much pressure as all
right this is ridiculous I don't see it
no he had like I don't know two million
followers
it keeps getting banned I guess uh click
on that why the video yeah we won't play
it for the fans I'll just
give them the cliff notes so he just
banned because he's probably was he
supposed to like fight videos of people
getting like messed up I would see like
kids falling down or people getting hurt
but he's like they're okay they're fine
I mean how would he know that but it
doesn't matter so stupid that means
those people kept reporting his account
so lame people and then they look in
yeah people suck man it's like I see
people it's enjoyable to watch that
stuff and they just took up so I I
thought maybe you felt the pressure from
keeping up with her sometimes you span
it's a shadow band welcome to the team
my man this first team all Shadow Bend
now you ain't Eddie Bravo band that's a
different thing Sam Tripoli man Sam
triple is like being like the rest of us
but Eddie bro there's a band The Shadow
band there's Eddie Bravo band Eddie like
he you type in his name like it just
it's just like no no he went too deep
man he went too deep for him
um so yeah we watched a little video
here
um so Derek Lewis it's not that he
because of pressure or he just didn't
feel like entertaining you guys anymore
on Instagram Instagram banned his
account because it people kept reporting
it for um certain things
like I posted on my story on my wall I
was talking about you know how those
bearded dragons
and uh I thought they I caught a lizard
in the backyard and thought they could
you know be friends and put in the tank
and they ripped his head off and ate
them alive and so then I caught a bigger
one I'm like right he's too big this
guy's too big he's gonna be friends with
him I'm like because my son really wants
another lizard and I don't want to buy
one because they're annoying and so we
got this bigger lizard put him back
there did I send him to the group chat I
didn't see it I thought I sent to the
group chat but then I post on my
Instagram story and then I you know
because a lizard eating another lizard
and I post that I was like I'm telling
you these bearded Lids are doing fool
with your cuteness man these things are
savages and this thing tears this lizard
up I'll show you guys when we get off
here I posted my Instagram story and I
was like uh that might get me more
banned that might get me taken down you
know it's nature it's nature yeah but
you never know if you know you got those
idiots who can report and you know
animal abuse and [__] like that so I
just took it down oh okay I thought
something happened no I was just like
yeah it's not worth it I mean he could
ruin your side it was like Saturday
morning too would ruin your Saturday if
you're a big lizard fan but it's just
nature baby Nature's metal had so many
deaths so many crazy deaths on that yes
I don't know how they get by it it must
be something to do with education and
nature
uh I don't know well like hey here's
education you know I don't think so no I
mean because your page isn't I also
think Instagram like you know
Instagram dictates who they like who
they don't that's how it goes I know I
hear you but um point is Derek Lewis
just got banned he just didn't walk away
from it so that's a shame uh I do think
he wins that fight though especially the
pressure's on him he can't rely into the
second or third round playing possum to
knock the guy out I think he gets it
done he needs to win man he's falling
some tough times he lost what four hours
last five
it's been tough for him man
really tough
um then you got a great fight and one
boy Thompson Michelle pierra that's a
fantastic fight I will take wonderboard
in that I assume Derek and Wonder Boy
the favorites in this
Michael Kiesza and Kevin Hollins a great
fight Derek is not the favorite
Derek is not the favorite one that's
150. that'd be my dog pick of the
weekend because he knows he has to get
done the first round at that elevation
Stephen his favorite though -17 as soon
as minus 170 favorite
hmm some good dog bets on this
um yeah because listen I like Wonder Boy
but anything could happen that fight
those boys are crazy yeah it's gonna be
fun but I'll take Wonder Boy I'll take
Derek Lewis Michael kiss Uh Kevin
Holland I assume Kevin Hollins the favor
of that gin
minus 145 yep it's right there okay
minus 145.
that's a good fight
yeah all the fights are like there's not
one bad fight on that main car no the
main card stocked yeah it's stacked
there's no way Derek Lewis and uh delima
doesn't
end in the finish one boy Thompson
pierra sometimes it's a little dicey if
Wonder Boy can get away we stay on the
outside these fights can be a little
boring if the guy didn't come forward
but Pierre's the same he always comes
forward he'll come forward so somebody's
gonna finish in that just say Kevin
Holland
uh that's a good fight
God so high I might go kyosa I'm so high
on him I think he's gonna be
Welterweight Champion he's falling a
little bit of tough times let me see his
record Jim
lost his last two sente lucay God I
guaranteed Luke I wouldn't submit him
there and he did a DARS joke and they
lost to Sean Brady he needs a win too
man
he's mowing through those welterweights
and he ran into
that harms out one I throw out so you're
gonna be two out of his last four
and the Thompson when he didn't want to
wrestle which is crazy so that was
insane yeah they beat punsonibio he
needed that one
um
yeah both I mean both of kind of fork
and wrote for Yesa and Kevin Holland
there I'll take Kevin Holland though uh
Ferguson Bobby green I mean I don't know
I mean I can't be purchased still doing
the damn thing first I'm probably a
bigger dog dude yeah who's gonna put
money on Ferguson plus 285 Bobby's minus
375 damn
that I mean that's offensive I mean Bob
got starched his last fight they're just
assuming Tony Ferguson's totally checked
out yeah I assume his last one
what what's a bigger Fall From Grace
Tony Ferguson or BJ Penn right now BJ
Penn still I think BJ Penn I think just
the because Tony was never like a legit
champ he was an interim Champion BJ Penn
I mean Mount Rushmore yeah
what they did still was just amazing
Legend but yeah that was a pretty he's a
legend I I I I only remember with that I
don't think of him running for governor
trying to get NASCAR to Hawaii I don't
none of that stuff just the legend he's
the coolest dude runs Hawaii this whole
family does John blockage Alex Pierre
that's actually my favorite car fight on
the card
even more so than Porey I'm intrigued by
this fight it could get man look at
those odds I gotta be honest I'm
surprised so the odds are minus 105
minus 125 basically pick them I'm a
little surprised just with Jan's
experience in MMA compared to oxpiera
you know Alex had the perfect route to
get to a world title they get to Izzy
gets the job done there and then gets
you know starched in his last outing
but he hasn't really fought a ton of big
heavy Grapplers
like yeah I'm not saying Jan's you know
khabib here but compared to Alex he's
khabib here
um
the magnet fight
and John would you know toss up not the
best fight we've ever seen
he and I think he's he has to be at
least four is he 38 or 40
40. he's 40.
have you eaten at the end of the world
but not ideal
um I just if if I'm the UFC I get when
you look at the light heavyweight
rankings you know Alex I think has a lot
of shine on coming off the Izzy fights
even though he lost his last one people
still love Alex
he can be your face of the light
heavyweight division
but out of
there's there's two fights John I mean
magumed if they if they really want to
scream they give him a magomed that's
just rude and then Jan's kind of a you
know a hybrid version has better
striking than magamed but isn't as good
as you know as a Grappler but he's no
punk down there
so
I get why the UFC is doing like all
right man if you're gonna be Champion
you gotta beat all comers I get that but
let's just get them to the the title
first
it's just that all the guys take out
margamed out of all the matchups it's
the least exciting
Jan's just you know he hits like a Mack
truck his grappling's not bad compared
to [__]
Alex he's you know he's leap years ahead
of him but when you think about Alex
Pierre Gary's a great fight
um rackets a great fight cry loves a
great fight Johnny walk is a phenomenal
and Anthony Smith is fun one ozomir is a
good one like they're good fights man
they're really really good fights and
we'll still see some of those but it'd
be I just feel like it it would do a lot
more for the UFC if Pierre was Champion
which I think he can be he just has to
get by this huge Destiny on he taking
that fight
I mean my brain tells me John me too
because he he handled Israel pretty much
my head says yeah my heart wants Alex
it's exciting this division would be so
fun if Alex was your champion
and it makes sense DC alluded to this
and broke it down why this isn't for the
light heavyweight interim Championship
because remember Yuri was Champion he
got hurt then Jamal Hill stepped in he
became Champion so he's technically the
champion but he's not we know Yuri
didn't lose the belt so then Mick
Maynard DC called him say why isn't this
for the championship fight he's like
because here's the champ this just makes
it complicated like because here he's
the champ so when he comes back he's
he's gonna fight for the title
you know for his belt Jamal Hill never
lost his belt he's hurt so it's just it
makes it all kind of dicey
so it makes more sense I get it
but I can't wait for that [__] fight
then Dustin boy just engagedy the BMF
title could care less if it's for a
title or not uh the final 2018 people
must have forgot I mean Justin gaichi
has changed I mean changed his fighting
style is still entertaining his [__] but
after he lost the dust Emporia he
changes fighting style to be a little
more controlled
um
you know so he lost it so he lost Eddie
Alvarez which was a wild fight and then
he lost to Dustin pore in the fourth
round but what was weird about that
fight is it wasn't going poory's way
going to that fourth round and he facet
the light kicks were a huge issue for
Dustin Poirier so I think Trevor knowing
Trevor Whitman they're gonna focused on
those light kicks you do got to be
careful there because what did finish
um just engaging that fourth round was
the counter to the light kick so unless
those leg kicks are just such as doing
significant damage where it doesn't
probably can't walk you can't answer the
Bell or get off his stool then it's
worth it but you gotta be careful invest
in so many light kicks because that's
all just important trains on that's how
he lost last time but
I do think it should be noted you know
the majority of the fans Emporia is
favored here
doesn't probably the the it was not
going his way in that first fight even
though he ended up winning it so
something to of note there but since
then apparently he's changed his
fighting style he beat James Vick which
was a crazy kill it's in Barboza
surrounding Tony Ferguson
uh lost khabib uh beat Chandler that's
his best win it's Chandler in a hot
second in a hot second because let's be
honest James Vic you know not a world
beater no disrespect SM Barbosa older at
the time gets starch Cerrone all the
[__] at the time he beats him Tony
Ferguson and we see where Tony's at
right
then he gets to khabib he gets
manhandled by khabib gets to Chandler
like I said his best win that was a
really good fight fight of the year and
then he gets a another shot at the
championship and he gets dealt with
pretty heavily by Charles Oliveira
still fan favorite but it's whenever he
fights the upper echelon guys he loses
2017 at restaurant Upper Echelon lost
loss khabib the toughest test lost
Charles Oliveira toughest test lost you
know so he beats those guys that are
right there but he's not beating the tip
of the spare guys
oh
and he says he's changed his style since
I think it's his success came from a
change of style and matchups he's
fighting a lot of older guys so it could
be I think it's a combination of both
he's just better in the chaos and then
you look at Dustin pore since they
fought
so he beat Eddie Alvarez who you know
Justin lost two he beat Max Holloway
um to become the interim Championship
then they both lost he khabib nothing to
get sad about beat Dan hooker that's a
good win you beat Connor twice lost
Charles Oliveira
and then they both beat Michael Chandler
but uh doesn't pour a handed
handle Chandler a lot smoother I think
um yeah I can see why people are taking
poor I think poor is a better overall
fighter strength the schedule is better
his wins at the highest level are better
um I know Justin gaichi
does well in the chaos I know he's they
say he's a change fighter I don't know
if I believe that I think it's
yeah you know maybe maybe not as a wild
man but he's still a wild man he's just
maybe a tad more control but I don't
think he can ever shake that it's in his
DNA which is what makes him great which
makes him The Human Highlight but I do
think that doesn't make you a world
champion I think does Emporia just does
something's better I do think we'll get
a little more grappling in this fight I
think poire is going to initiate it
Porey has a significant advantage on the
ground when it comes to jiu jitsu just
just not just in case he's cup of tea
just does not gravitate towards Jutsu
doesn't really work on it does Emporia
is a legit black belt on the ground it's
important does implement uh wrestling
more than just in gaichi
Justin took down fazive physiv got right
back up but I do think Dustin's gonna
incorporate grappling more especially if
uh the light kicks are success early on
by just engaging I think could negate
that with takedowns something from
kicking and I would get into the head I
would say I could see poor a winning via
submission
so I'll take for you
what do you got Jen
uh you already mentioned Tom aspinall
calling out Jon Jones if he were to win
against me I don't think they ever fight
Cyril yeah
I don't think there's much left for John
to do what do you think of Paul Craig's
call out of Bo nickel I love it right
I absolutely love it I'm a huge Paul
Craig fan he looks great at middleweight
that's what he but she should have been
fighting all along so I thought he
looked great at middleweight it's a huge
test for uh bo nickel definitely has the
advantage when it comes to striking from
what we've seen but I would be curious
if Beau Nichols forced to strike because
of the danger of the ground with Paul
Craig who's a phenomenal Jiu Jitsu
practitioner so it'd be such a good test
for bow nickel again it's all up to you
see how fast do they want bow nickel to
get to the top
this isn't a bad test it's a big one
dude definitely a big test big one
I wonder if the FC that's what
everybody's saying he broke docker's
Army the same to Eric Anders maybe
Paul's just using good because he's just
a weak guy from Scotland
wait who said that I didn't hear that
yeah he did look good and he did win by
strikes which is they look good yeah
so he beat the number 14 guys so I
assume they put in the top 15. yeah I
mean I'm not mad at what I want to do is
to be a top 15 guy I'm Number Nine at
light heavyweight
he did [__] up Jamal Hill people forget
doesn't matter I kind of like Bo nickel
fight nobody wants to fight him but then
if he takes it down he better be good at
passing guard because I'm very good at
retaining guard yeah one of the best
he's a name he's the name and he can
play into my game plan where he gets in
tight takes me down It just fits me
better yeah I love the fight
again I wonder what the if the UFC's
like ah too much too soon Paul Craig's a
[__] yeah that's what I'm
thinking too maybe from the USA how do
we risk the hyperbo nickel which guy
like Paul Craig
man Parker's good guy to bet on though
you know yeah because if you want him to
steal bow nickel shine I would invest in
Paul Craig Paul Craig's character man
yeah great fighter too
yeah I like it I'd like to it'd be a
even if they don't do it next in the
next three fights like maybe one test
right outside top 15 and then do Paul
Craig but I like to test for Bo nickel
what do you got Jen uh so there's a
bunch of bad announcements after our
last show
Oliveira too
that's gonna be for UFC 294
are you more excited for marketev
Charles Oliveira on that card too are
you more excited for hamzat Palo Costa
which one gets you which one would you
pay for first
uh it's just because I I love seeing
Hamza fight Hamza but yeah so that's why
but I mean don't say it with your chest
chin I don't make excuses
I would pay for over Charles Oliveira
yeah
yeah because we we saw it
it wasn't that it's not like
it's not like Charles Oliver has been on
this since he lost a marketev it's been
years and he's gotten so much better
it's like kind of just happened we know
how that fight goes
not that excited for it I know
everyone's high on Charles de Lavere
after that fight and he looked
phenomenal but it's just like I don't
see him beating machachev so I'm not
that excited for it hamzat Paulo Casa
take my Goddamn money Daddy
how much I guess anyone honestly it's
just he's so fun to watch
yeah he's great yeah and I was talking
with a guy who knows UFC better than
most and uh I go I can't wait for Hamza
Polo costumes dude I think Costa
starches something like what what Angels
dude think about uh Paula Costa fought
um oh I'm what's his [__] name
oh the Cuban wrestler oh y'all y'all
were in yours he went toe-to-toe with yo
Romero like when his prime yellow Romero
like yeah but he also had that [__]
fight with Luke rock on his last outing
did you forget he's like oh yeah I'm
like that's that's the podcast of now
yeah I think I think hometop mops the
floor of them I don't think he's
competitive but I ride hamzatz beard
hairs so [__] hard dude
I just I yeah I don't know what it is I
just don't see the guy and then everyone
will go back I'm like yeah well if he
fights the same way he fought about
against Gilbert burns like here's the
thing worst fight of his life in the
office he decided just to stand Toe to
Toe with Gilbert Burns exchanged shots
fought like a dumbass early in his
career you know in the UFC still won
though like that's what you're gonna
that's where you're in a harp on
the guy learned from it look what he
does like Kevin Hall and like oh my
goodness Gilbert's like the top of the
top too so it's like obviously yeah
that's the thing it's not like deal with
some punk like dude what
Gilbert's a Savage he went toe-to-toe
and just stood in the pocket and still
beat him dude
so I just I don't know what podcast is
gonna do
it could be wrong it's MMA could be
wrong
it's gonna be fun to watch this one
and uh you already mentioned that you're
doing a fight companion for this but Rob
font stepped in
and he's fighting Corey sandhagen
yeah I'm listen I'm a huge Rob font fan
all those boys that they're doing cartel
out there
um the Winter Hill Gang as I like to
call them they don't like that though uh
but I I love Rob find I love what Calvin
cater all the boys out there love those
guys but
um it's just I'm you know I've known
Corey since he was 16 we've been over
this I love Corey course you know good
buddy
I was so excited for him to fight to
fight Umar nagamedov
because Umar is like this Boogeyman
division that wants to fight him and it
and is there's something about Corey
when you know he was on food truck he's
like I want to fight everybody I don't
care what they're ranked because when I
become Champion I want to say that I
earned it and I fought all comers so
it's like it's very Samurai very in his
you know uh train of thought where he's
like yeah I'll fight Umar because you
know no one wants to fight him I think
he's top five guy if I don't fight him
now I'm gonna have to fight him later
might as well see if I can pass the test
now otherwise don't deserve to be
Champion so there's something cool about
that there's there's this mystery with
Umar there I'm just worried for Corey
when they go okay here's Rob fauna two
weeks notice he's not as hyped for it he
I wouldn't say he's as good as a boxer
as uh Rob font but he does everything
else better and there's a lot of hype on
Umar and I think for Corey you know what
what do they do you know he's gonna be a
big favorite if he does beat Rob is that
enough to give him the title shot what
do they do there you know so I just
worry about the letdown of the you know
you're supposed to be fighting this
undefeated Prospect and there's all this
momentum and you beat him it shows you
know you're true to your word and then
he gets hurt and like here's Rob font
who's a Savvy vet coming off that
Adriana's win which is you know amazing
but
I'm just worried about the come down for
Corey there that's the only kind of
Pitfall I can see other than that he
should win the fight he's especially on
the ground
but I'm worried about it
uh I don't think we talked about this
this probably happened after the show
last week but Juka suplexes won't be
fighting or apparently won't be fighting
Israel to sign in so Israel's calling
out Sean Strickland yeah what else would
you do yeah
how crazy is it you could have listen I
don't think either guy once but you
could have Sean Strickland and Colby
Covington as your champions
going in 2024.
he could also have Trump as your
president
insane dude wild wild time yeah wild
wild wild days man
um
yeah I I definitely think uh du police
is definitely more dangerous for Izzy's
because his style can't really train for
but don't sleep on Sean Strickland
either man yeah he he does something
right you know but obviously stylist
he's gonna be a pretty sizable Underdog
for a reason
there's just not much for it that's why
you see push the duplicity's fight and
all that like there's just not much form
out there but Strickland and uh Izzy
have a history like one of the press
crimes together they talk so much [__]
the build up is gonna be great
yeah but yeah that drink as fight would
have been awesome are you not excited
about Strickland I think once it gets
closer and then the build up I like it
because strix is gonna say a lot of [__]
like he has a lot of inside stuff that
he's talking about which is really
[__] up yeah that's what makes it fun
and he's strickless no punk man and he
probably learned from Alex Pierre fight
like all right dude you gotta grapple
some you can't you know you're not at
that level when it comes to kickboxing
and striking you know like he's [__]
good but you don't want to sit in the
pocket and trade with these world-class
Strikers
so I would assume you learn from that
all right
um Jake Paul tweeted out that he was
gonna fight uh Nate Diaz
in the pfl cage and he offered him 10
million dollars he says the offer still
stands and then Nate replied he wants he
needs more than that
but 10 mil to do the PFO gonna cost more
than that dog
uh yeah I mean I don't want to see him
fight in a cage the even the bot you
know all right man you pushing with the
box and I'll tune in yeah and then cage
is like no like you don't want for Jake
he doesn't want his first MMA fight
against Nate Diaz
no I mean I get if in like how much
money is enough for Jake like you're
good man you don't need to do this [__]
it's because all it's going to do is
defame you he's not mean Nate Diaz and
like cage that's just not happening it's
just stupid you know I love Jake Jake's
great he's not being Nate Diaz I'm not
[__] cage fight it's silly
and uh this headline right here Jake did
an interview and he said that his team
him and his team would be happy with 400
500 000 buys pay-per-view buys do you
think it'll do more than that or it
seems kind of like a I don't think it's
doing more no one's talking about are
they yeah that's true I always gauge
fights it's a weird way to gauge fights
but I always Gage fights when I'm at
Star Wars get my coffee and the Barista
the people around like oh man what do
you think of that everyone asked me what
do you think of this fight this fight no
one's asking about Jake Paul and Nate
Diaz okay and Nate's really not doing
any of the build up
they think man with the SAG actors I'm
taking a strike too from any promotion
and Jake's like where was all this you
talked all this [__] before we signed
the fight now we get the fight you're
not selling it and he's like we're good
man
but he's just training maybe he's focus
on trading for the you know yeah
but I I 400 500k units would be great I
think we gotta change our level of
expectations these pay-per-view models
like everyone thinks of the Connor and
The Floyds and stuff like that but again
with the legal stream especially with
Jake Paul's fan base which it's rampant
I think yeah they're taking that
consideration like if we hit 500k this
thing's a home run
because everyone's these young kids man
they don't they're Savages
they're like oh Jake has enough money he
doesn't care if we illegally download it
which it's an issue man
do you think earlier even when he fought
maybe after aspirin like earlier when he
was like when it first came out do you
think they would have done better him
and Nate no because I think he had to
prove himself
I think I think it would have done
better before he fought Tommy Fury
undefeated that would have been the move
but you know he took the gambling loss
with diamond Fury
who saw that coming too I know but
you know it's doing its thing still
making money yeah I there's just no hype
around this fight maybe it's because
we're focused on UC 291 I don't know I
don't know but so Nate was on um your
boy Bradley Martin's podcast and then
Bradley Martin I guess he did this with
Devin Haney too was like do you think he
could he could beat me in a street fight
he asked Nate the same question he's
been on fight man before and he was he
was like mad [__] Dylan down and stuff
I'm like no you hey he seems to think
that he could beat these guys up in a
street fight
yeah I'm a seed Bradley I'm going on his
show later today and I'll definitely
address them I love you man but it's
just not the way to go yeah and because
you think about he's a he's like
ignorance is bliss like he's
you know he's a big guy in the gym so
he's thinking that correlates to like
fighting yeah he's also I think he's
saying in a street fight for all these I
don't think he said in a box no he said
street fight straight up so he's
thinking like he like even if Nate got
him in an arm bar or something he can
pick up and like Slam in the car like
the Hulk or some [__] like they're just
like Rampage Jacks him down the cement
he doesn't realize how good these guys
are like he doesn't grab it at a high
high level
it's just not
I don't know
so Nate answered him and he was like
really cool about it too yeah dude you'd
be dead yeah yeah yeah yeah which I mean
yeah now that we know fighting a lot
more after watching all these damn
matches we realize the difference
between regular human people see I don't
think people do really no I don't think
the I'd say 98 of society doesn't you
know what that's why online there's a
lot of [__] talk that's why in person
you know you see like like that one guy
talk [__] to Paul Felder he said I'm
gonna see you after him I was like well
I'm right here right now what do you
what do you mean after the guy's like uh
it's like but when it's something that's
just all they specialize in it's just so
stupid it's no different than you know
being like I I could make that same pass
Patrick my home screen it's like that's
all they do dude I can act just like Tom
Cruise man that's easy just jumps out of
the plane and then he can't it's
literally all he does
it just you know
it's just part of society people are
stupid it's just they don't have the
experience just seeing Brian with
Bradley Martin grappling yeah Brian look
at the difference in size oh that's
insane and he's 50 something yeah and
he'll swept them Brian did do get
wrestling and he freaking swept him good
dude but and you know and I don't I
don't think we'll realize like even
Dylan Dennis like you know brown belt
world champions the black belt now like
the
how fast he could get a hold of Bradley
Martin's ankle and snap it Bradley
thinks he'll he gets it and he's gonna
be able to just pick him up no no like
it's all they do dude against other
black belts at a high level like your
size means nothing I'm sure the strength
means something but not enough to it
doesn't when it comes to that like those
guys know how to use leverage and what
the defense you're gonna do they've seen
a million times they there's also ways
they can make it so you can't pick him
up and slam them it's just there's a
million ways that but they don't know
this like no he goes for my arm I'll
just pick him up it's like there's stuff
they can do to make it so he can't pick
him up they can prevent you from picking
them up they can control your posture
with their legs dude you don't know what
you're talking about
but that's what makes Bradley you know
successful is that confidence in himself
you know because he used that in all
aspects of business he's just wrong in
this one
probably a good dude he just doesn't
know
I love Bradley he just doesn't know
um all right so this is pretty cool uh
Michael Venom page was on airless show
and he said that he's now a free agent
after being Bellator for 10 years I know
he's been a you know he it just never
came to fruition I thought he was gonna
be the face of Bellator they tried and
they always lost like that big fight you
know the the Lima fight and stuff like
that so he always he lost right when he
got to that cusp of it
um
you know I wonder if he's gonna sign
with Bellator I feel like one
Championship but he could fit for him
there's a lot of fun matchups for him
there he could do both kickboxing and
MMA one Championship but he was at the
show he was at the show and they showed
him which is yeah there's some fun
matchups for him too wonder boy yeah
dude so many matchups Pierre Wonder Boy
some great matchups yeah but Wonderboy
is probably the best one I'm just
curious what the UFC is gonna throw his
way as far as money-wise Oh I thought
you meant like they want to beat him
right away because he was oh they want
to beat him right away oh they're gonna
throw him to the [__] wolves that's
what they do but
um I'm just wondering as far as
conversation how much do they think he's
his values right now
she's 21-2 dude
yeah
he's a good [__] fighter
damn you could read that yeah man jeez
all righty uh Darren till posted some
pictures I don't know where this is
because I try to look at his his Twitter
and it's not there but apparently he was
posting pictures saying he's in the best
shape of his life he's also on tr2 I
mean that's what they're saying but I
don't know he is no he he admitted it he
left the UFC so you get on stuff I don't
know if it's trt but he's on stuff that
you thought it would flag that's why he
technically retired you know just so he
can get his leg right I'm not it's not a
bad idea I mean I agree it's not that
bad he looks good dude I hope he gets he
comes back and does work
Darren till was one of my favorites
and you mentioned Dylan Dennis earlier
so I guess till wants to I don't this is
lame it's not gonna happen but he wants
to fight Dylan danis on the undercard of
the Paul Diaz one Dylan dance ain't
taking that fight he posted this didn't
tell would [__] murder him yeah
in MMA this would result in a quick one
side fight for me
well I understand what he wants a boxing
guys but Intel doesn't seem to
understand that I would dominate him in
any sport with these remember once a
quarter always one [__]
why does he have that gun I don't know
yeah Dennis is hilarious
um so so is he saying he won't do it in
a boxing contest I don't know that'd be
a bad idea for Dylan yeah I mean
I mean tells a Savage on the feet Savage
and all he has to do is focus out and
you're fighting against a straight
Grappler like it's a terrible idea for
Dylan Dallas
that's the fight's not happening but fun
to talk about
and finally Connor's team on The
Ultimate Fighter he it's not a sweep one
of his dudes won yeah I watched it and
the the punch was crazy like this part
this one double fist tour talking about
that Thor hammer yeah
but it's so funny Conor's reaction oh he
dude he runs
he runs like my kids run when when my
wife yells at him he runs around
[Applause]
laughs
I mean to to be fair it's like and that
was the number one seed oh snap that kid
that they beat but to be fair to Conor
like again I don't know what do you see
they don't think this stuff through it
he wasn't set up for Success on this
Ultimate Fighter season like this was
made I don't think I I just don't think
anybody looked into it but this was not
made for him to succeed veterans versus
newcomers yeah it's not gonna go your
way at all so he looks bad thoughts kind
of be pissed man but he did pick that
though right
uh I forget who picked I forget how they
did it it's just a bad idea yeah
since the jump I got these poor kids hit
their ass but this is not how the show
could should go almost a sweep yeah
pretty crazy
yeah I did that that show it's just
you know so you're gonna have the
veterans win but they've already had
their time in the UFC
and so if they're veterans you're not
going to build them up like your young
Prospect so you need to toss them to the
the top 15 right away they're gonna get
eaten alive like no stars coming off
this show it you know I hate to be
shitty about it
yeah
this also is a little bit of I don't
know if this is controversial so Mark
Goddard I think this is LFA I think
Mark's the best ref we have okay so oh
no this is uh cage Warriors so he uh
said the guy was hidden behind the head
and I'll just play this clip for you
sorry in this corner
yeah
it's right behind the head there it's
hard for me to tell but yeah
from the back you gotta at least hit the
air and you went off on him let me see
there stay there who are you talking to
I'm looking right at it twice I don't
need too much to replay will blatant to
the back of his head
Chris come in stay away from the corner
stay away from your corner is Mark
Goddard a dad because there's some daddy
Vibes that's why I talk to my kids at
the park
s you just gotta be on it man
minimum twice minimum twice
[Music]
for the
not not even close will and I mean you
know the world goes like no it was like
here he's like dude you're off
the best ref doing right now is Mark
Goddard by the way uh the kid that did
the will he did end up winning anyways
that's good for him yeah
um also back to tough what do you think
of Patty pimbler
it's fun to call out to peria but he's
not even the top 50 Patty's name in the
top 15. like his his his Fame is higher
than his ranking so in the ufcs would
never do this
like what no I want to fight for the
title like my next fight's for the title
not a guy's not running the top 15 I
don't give a [__] how famous he is and
for the ultimate fighter that no
absolutely not
alrighty oh he's making fun of Josh
but I can finish Josh I'm in my sleep
yeah I love Patty yes I love Patty's
confidence and he has Star Quality
written all over him he just hasn't done
the work and not gone yet he will I
think he'll get there and be a top 10
guy he's not he's not there close now
like you know the Gordon fight probably
didn't win that fight man and then
you're making fun of Josh Abbott geez
dude
I wouldn't do it but keep doing your
thing Patty
um
this I thought was pretty interesting
someone did the stats here about the
simulators between
um Dustin pori and Justin gaichi yep
both the 34 both their former light uh
weight or yeah lightweight interim
Champs both Lots the same guy via sub
both have 13 letters in their name both
fought for the UFC belt twice both beat
Michael Chandler both won their previous
fights both of their name rhyme Dustin
Johnson don't do the last name there
you're gonna struggle uh both are
exciting to watch that one's stupid I
know both sweat both are white males
um both went six and two have to find
each other with four fish two decisions
yeah a lot of similarities some people
can actually just dig up all this stuff
which is crazy it's called research Doug
I know but that's a lot some random
research she's like that's crazy they
get on the computer like searching [__]
and look at stuff man it's lame
um let's go here because the only reason
I bring this up bring this up because
you watch that show Euphoria I watched
the first season dude do you know this
kid so okay this guy named Joe but let
me see what it looks like is he from
season one oh yeah he was the little
baby kid so he's yeah
Jake signed him for his MVP promotions
to fight the Box
yeah so his amateur career he was like
what does it say 18 17 damn 80 ballots
multiple Junior Amateur tournament
victories five five-time Georgia state
championship damn
I looked at the box wreck though and I
just saw this okay well that's right
maybe that's it that's somebody else
maybe it's someone else to you I don't
know
but that's cool yeah yeah he was a
little baby uh drug dealer him and his
brother drug dealers on that show
I don't watch the second season got too
dark made me depressed I don't like
watching stuff with kids
well you mean like teenagers yeah yeah
it just feels weird the teenagers have
you seen that movie kids no way back in
the day that was awkward too man yeah
and it was when he watched it that's
when I realized I don't like watching
yeah
uh oh I saw this yeah dude Sean
Strickland needs to grow his hair out he
was a [__] dime dude he looks like
um the guy from Beauty and the Beast
yeah he looks like a prince yeah it's
like his everything facial structure
hair a new model
but there you go
yeah he looked [__] beautiful I'm
with that guy
I thought that was funny yeah he was a
damn good looking dude man I had no idea
neither did I shaved his head well
that's all it invites though that's all
that matters is that a chin that's it
all right kids uh I have Luke Thomas
breaking down UFC 291 on Thursday for
you guys and Earl Spence and Crawford as
well bringing one of the best of them
Biz to talk to you guys about it so that
will be fun Saturday we have a cop ass
fight campaign with a very special
lineup I can't wait it's UFC 291 going
down this Saturday we are live Cowboys
fight campaign 7 P.M Pacific on thick
boy YouTube that's important just in
case you yawn Alex Pierre Tony Ferguson
Bobby green chiasa Kevin Holland Stephen
Wonderboy Thompson Michael biera Derek
Lewis in one freaking round at altitude
Marcos delima it's a fun [__] card
man all right and again you got Crawford
and Spence fighting as well so we had a
fun weekend coming up kids if you see me
around town say what's up Friday I have
one show at the laugh I'm sorry one show
at the Ice House shopping friends we got
Jay Moore Trey Stewart will Burkhart
Skyler Stone we got a bunch of people
um on the show so chop and Friends one
show only 8 P.M that thing will sell out
get your tickets right now if you're
listening to this
Pasadena Ice House July 28th that's this
Friday shopping friends one show and
Phoenix uh two shows August 11th that's
a Friday only because I have to be at
fights on Saturday so August 11th stand
up live on my favorite spots Phoenix
Arizona you can catch me at JT Wings
when I'm not on stage it's my favorite
Wings in the country JT Wing shout to
them it's right outside Phoenix that's
free it's things called Paradise or some
[__] like that either way Phoenix is
August 11th one show only I'm sorry one
day two shows August 11th at stand up
live in the hot ass Phoenix Arizona area
then Omaha Nebraska just got announced
that's one night only as well Omaha
Nebraska August 16th Kansas City
Missouri will be trying your barbecue
there August 17th and then Ohio end of
August August 30th one night only at
Liberty Township Ohio Columbus Ohio
August 31st I'm in Spokane Washington
September 21st to the 23rd bunch more
dates coming up all right guys I've been
chilling this summer for a reason but
start in August your boy's back on the
road all right guys love you stay safe
enjoy the fights see you around